Dozens of hopeful TV show creators head to
the big networks every year, looking to get
their show on the air.
Very few make it to the pilot stage and even
less actually make it to series.
However, even with such a long and competitive
process, not all of the shows that hit the
air are instant hits.
Some, in fact, are so badly received by audiences,
they're axed before they even get off the
ground.
Here are some TV shows that were canceled
before they hit the five-episode mark.
Anchorwoman
It only took one night for Fox to decide they
didn't want to see any more of their reality
show Anchorwoman.
"In 15 days, her dream comes true.
Lauren Jones at 5.
She's coming."
In August of 2007, the show was canceled after
airing two back-to-back episodes, reaching
only 2.7 million viewers.
The would-be series followed former The Price
Is Right model Lauren Jones as she tried to
become a news anchor at a Texas TV station.
The series pitted Jones against the station's
5 p.m. anchor, Annalisa Petralia, and Fox
even promoted their rivalry on their website.
But needless to say, the show was trashed
by critics once it premiered.
The LA Times concluded,
"If you hate women, men, Texas, Los Angeles,
television news and any of the social progress
made by Americans in the 20th century, then
Anchorwoman is the show for you."
The Beautiful Life: TBL
Mischa Barton's dramatic exit from The O.C.
may have left fans reeling, but they still
weren't ready to follow Marissa Cooper to
her next project.
Barton's 2009 CW series The Beautiful Life:
TBL, only lasted for two episodes before it
was canceled due to low ratings.
Even though it featured a beautiful star-studded
cast, and was executive produced by Ashton
Kutcher, it still only brought in just over
1 million viewers for its second episode.
Fans were upset to see the show canceled,
and more than 8,000 people signed a petition
to bring it back, to no avail.
Kutcher was adamant about still getting the
produced episodes of the show out to the public
when it went off the air, landing a deal with
Hewlett-Packard to have them all uploaded
to YouTube for fans to watch, ad free.
Coupling
The Office may be the model example of a British
TV series turning into a successful American
sitcom, but many attempts to take comedies
stateside have failed.
One such experiment was Coupling, NBC's 2003
attempt at adapting the BBC Two romantic comedy
series from Doctor Who's Steven Moffat.
The show is based on his relationship with
producer Sue Vertue.
NBC started looking into the show when Friends
was nearing the end of its run.
However, their attempts to bring Coupling
to the States were troubled from the start,
with the network shooting and then scrapping
a pilot because they felt Moffat's script
was too confusing.
Three of the six lead roles were recast when
the pilot was re-shot.
"You want us to split up?"
"Yes."
"I don't accept."
Coupling ended up getting the axe after only
four low-rated episodes on NBC, although Moffat
had much more success with the British version,
which ran for four series.
Moffat blamed NBC for the show's cancellation
and later said,
"I learned not to work in America.
I say that slightly facetiously, but truthfully,
I'm British, what is the point of me going
to try to make it somewhere else?"
Ironside
Remakes may be all the rage nowadays, but
not all of them are successful.
Such was the case with NBC's 2013 attempt
at remaking the popular '60s and '70s cop
procedural Ironside, this time with Blair
Underwood starring as the title character,
a wheelchair-bound police officer who solves
the city's most difficult cases.
"How the hell'd you see that?"
"I got a different view of the world from
down here."
Underwood's take on the show was imagined
as grittier and darker than the original,
which didn't sit well with viewers.
The show was also hit with controversy from
disability rights advocates, with some groups
calling out NBC for casting a non-disabled
actor in the role of a disabled character.
(The show's producers claimed they needed
an able-bodied actor for flashback sequences,
pre-wheelchair.)
The show was trashed by critics, airing only
three episodes before it was pulled from the
schedule.
Made in Jersey
Being shuffled to Friday nights is never a
good sign, and the 2012 CBS procedural Made
in Jersey was sentenced to the fatal slot
before it even started.
The legal drama starred Janet Montgomery as
a New Jersey born-and-raised attorney who
gets a job at a big New York City law firm.
"This isn't my first murder case.
I did major crimes in Trenton."
"Trenton.
I bet you're amazing with a jury.
They must totally relate to you."
The show received mixed reviews from critics,
but didn't fare well in the ratings.
After premiering to 7.8 million viewers, its
second episode dropped to 5.8 million.
CBS ended up pulling the show and replacing
it with Undercover Boss after just two episodes.
The Paul Reiser Show
Launching a show with a big name comedian
has worked well in the past, but that wasn't
the case for NBC's The Paul Reiser Show.
The 2011 series featured the Mad About You
actor as a former TV star who decides to find
his next big project after taking a few years
off to be with his family.
"I'm exactly famous enough so it's never good.
Only bad."
Although Reiser holds four Golden Globe nominations
for his work on Mad About You, critics were
less kind when it came to his own sitcom,
slamming it in part for feeling like a less
fun copy of Curb Your Enthusiasm.
The show premiered to only 3.3 million viewers
and its second episode dropped to 2.5 million.
NBC pulled it and replaced it with reruns
of The Office.
In a prickly appearance on The Tonight Show,
Reiser joked,
"It turns out they said we enjoy missing you
more than actually having you."
The Playboy Club
Following the lives of 1960s playboy bunnies
may seem like a great idea for a TV show,
but NBC's The Playboy Club proved it definitely
wasn't.
The 2011 historical drama featured Eddie Cibrian
as an attorney with political aspirations
who frequented the notorious Playboy Club.
The Club's bunnies featured future stars Amber
Heard, Jenna Dewan, and Laura Benanti.
"I'm gonna be the first chocolate centerfold.
I AM!
You can't discriminate against these babies."
The Playboy Club felt some backlash, with
the Parents Television Council calling the
show "degrading and sexualizing" and asking
audiences to boycott.
Their request was backed up by activist Gloria
Steinem, who said the show portrayed the "tackiest
place on earth" as "glamorous."
Although many blamed the behind-the-scenes
drama for the show's bad buzz, some insiders
offered other reasons for the show's failure
to connect with audiences.
One source said,
"It was a fundamentally flawed concept.
It's a soap, which inherently appeals to women.
But it's a brand so tied to men.
I just think it was doomed from the start."
The series brought in only five million viewers
in its premiere, falling to 3.8 million and
3.2 million for its final two episodes.
We Are Men
The quick demise of CBS' We Are Men proves
that sometimes even big stars aren't enough
to save a show.
The comedy series brought together Tony Shalhoub,
Kal Penn, and Jerry O'Connell, along with
Rob Greenberg, but their collective star power
couldn't prevent the show from getting the
axe after two episodes.
"Dad you know Fiona's mom would totally go
out with you."
"I'll ask her to lunch."
"Great!
She's super nice and has really big boobs."
"Or dinner."
We Are Men premiered to 6.4 million viewers,
dropping to 5.4 million viewers for its second
episode.
The show failed to hold onto the audience
of its lead in, How I Met Your Mother, and
its performance made it a disappointing precursor
to CBS' other big comedy 2 Broke Girls.
The network determined that reruns of The
Big Bang Theory — and, eventually, Mike
and Molly — would fare better in the slot.
Wicked City
The Ed Westwick-led drama, Wicked City, was
set in 1982 Los Angeles and followed two police
detectives on a mission to capture the notorious
Hollywood Slayer.
And it lasted only three episodes.
"What are you feeling?"
"Terrified."
"There's no turning back now."
Wicked City was canceled midway through production
on its eighth episode, but the show's producers
were allowed to finish it up so that it could
become the show's "finale," for online streaming.
Executive producer Laurie Zacks assured fans
at the time that the final episode made the
series' story "complete."
Work It
Some shows seem like they are doomed right
from the premise, and Work It may be a prime
example.
The ill-advised ABC sitcom starred Ben Koldyke
and Amaury Nolasco as two recently laid-off
men who decide to remedy their situation by
posing as women to get jobs at a pharmaceutical
company.
"Excuse me."
"Oh my God."
"Help me.
Please."
The show was, predictably, met with controversy
from many LGBTQ groups, including GLAAD, who
said that the show was harmful to the transgender
community.
GLAAD's then-Acting President Mike Thompson
said that the show would contribute to transphobia
and the idea that trans people are "men pretending
to be women" rather than people living their
lives authentically.
The show earned even more criticism when the
pilot aired, with Puerto Rican activists taking
objection to Nolasco's character saying in
the pilot that, because he is Puerto Rican,
he would be good at selling drugs.
But, controversy aside, Work It just wasn't
a good show.
The series was absolutely trashed by critics,
and sat at a five percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
After two episodes, it was sent to "work it"
wherever TV shows go when they die.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!